is worried
the farmer from poland north central sri
lanka says the yield from his paddy
field has dropped by nearly half
with debts to pay and costs rising every
day he says farmers are struggling
we have already pawned our tractors our
spraying machines our wives jewelry even
their wedding rings have been pawned
home rice cookers and sewing machines
have all been borrowed against
dharma tillaka and thousands like him
across the country blamed president
gotaber rajapaksa's decision last year
to ban chemical fertilizer pesticides
and we decides for the lower yields
officers from the statistics department
are assessing how much of the harvest
has been affected
one agriculture source told al jazeera
yields have fallen by 40 to 50 percent
because of the fertilizer ban the
president said the measure was aimed at
making sri lankans healthier and
switching to 100 organic agriculture
but it was removed six months later
after widespread protests
says the idea was a good one but the way
it was quickly implemented was wrong
farmers say they were not consulted
about the move and are angry at a
short-sighted experiment they say has
caused them dearly
we never thought this would happen in
poland which was so self-sufficient what
we want is to chase this government out
because of this injustice that i came
here today
the politicians who rode from 1977 must
take responsibility for this crisis they
are the ones who dragged our country
into the situation
the anger brought thousands of
protesters including dharmathelika to
polanaro in the north central province
the government especially the president
he clearly emphasized that this plan was
made
in order to establish organic farming
system in sri lanka but that is not the
reason so the government did not have
enough dollars to bring down fertilizers
from overseas so because of that this
problem was created and the farmers are
better they are better to the core most
farmers told al jazeera they rely on
their harvest to clear deaths and build
a stock of rice for their own use and
money to last them through till the next
harvest but let alone settling deaths
they now fear not having enough food for
their families
minister of agriculture mahinda nanda
aloot gamake has announced the
government will spend 200 million
dollars to help the farmers but the
farmers who are yet to receive the
payout say the rates do not cover their
losses
protests against the government's
inability to control rising prices and
address shortages of essential goods
have been increasing in recent months
the farming community has been growing
rice in these areas for hundreds of
years and say if the government cannot
address the current crisis it must
resign
mina fernandez al-jazeera colombo